>>Stacy Brown-Philpot: Good afternoon.
My name is Stacy Brown-Philpot and I am an
Entrepreneur in Residence at Google Ventures.
And I'm excited to introduce our guests today
from Question Bridge.
So Question Bridge started, I guess the concept
back in 1996, when Chris Johnson came up with
the idea of unprompted Q &A as a way of getting
into the minds and the hearts and the beliefs
of the African American community in San Diego.
Chris is a filmmaker and is notably known
for "The Roof Is On Fire" that he produced
with a woman named Suzanne Lacy.
And it was aired on Crime TV.
And he's gone on to do many other things but
he's currently a professor of photography
at the California College of Arts.
So Hank found out about what Chris had done
and talked to him.
I guess a decade or more than a decade later.
And talked to him about this project and proposed
the idea of doing something similar for black
males.
Hank's work has been exhibited all over the
world and some of the more famous places,
like the Guggenheim, and the Museum of Modern
Art.
And one of his films along the way was featured
at the Sundance Film Festival.
So these two great minds thinking about media
and art and photography.
And the black man.
Have come together into an inspiring project.
For the last four years, I think it was, they
went to 11 cities and spoke with over 150
black men.
Just to ask questions.
And hear the answers.
And it was unprompted.
I think they got about 1500 conversations
out of this project.
And the idea was that people would ask a question
and someone else would answer that question.
Different person, different mind, as a way
of bridging the gap between socioeconomic
status and also age status.
So they've got some interactive things they're
gonna show us today.
I think Chris said it well when he describes
this project as a "unrehearsed, totally spontaneous
expression of the truth."
And I'm sure you'll enjoy what they both have
to say today.
And if you wanna see more you can visit the
Oakland Museum where their exhibit will be
on display until July 8th.
So please welcome Hank Thomas and Chris Johnson.
Thank you.
[applause]
>>Chris: Well, I'll begin.
Thank you very much for being here.
I wanna say that it's really an honor to be
here.
And I wanna thank Daphne Mews and Anne Farmer
for making this possible for us.
And as she said, we're here to talk about
a project called "Question Bridge Black Males"
which has a really ambitious goal.
What we intend to do with this project is
actually change the way people understand
the nature of black male consciousness.
Which sounds like a lofty goal but I think
you can understand, given the things that
are happening in our culture right now.
And the news.
Why that's really important to do.
One of the things I hope we get the chance
to talk about maybe when we do questions and
answers is exactly why would an artist try
to take on an issue like that and how to go
about it.
So what we've done is prepare a little clip
to show you just what our methodology is.
To give you a sense of what we're doing, and
so, this is our trailer.
[silence]
>>Male #1: Black man.
>>Male #2: Do you wanna get out of the situation
that you're in.
>>Male #3: What is the reluctance for taking
responsibility for our people and our communities?
>>Male #4: Are your children better or worse
off as a result of your involvement?
>>Male #5: Why wouldn't you be happy with
your son being gay?
>>Male #6: Why are you so violent?
>>Male #7: Why do you have that "take" mentality?
>>Male #8: Why are you afraid of being intelligent?
>>Male participants: Why?
Why?
>>Male #9: What I wanna know is
>>Male #10: Why?
[silence]
>>Male #11: I believe that we have incorporated
a lot of things that are unhealthy to us.
>>Male #12: we are supposed to be tough.
>>Male #13: I can't let 'em see no type of
sucker.
>>Male #14: Along with various other stereotypes.
>>Male #15: The level of mentorship in our
community is not as strong as it possibly
could be.
>>Male #16: When I came up, crack was a quick
way for a black man to make a million dollars.
>>Male #17: Sometimes I think because we think
we're black we're some other kind of human
beings.
But we are just like most other human beings.
[silence]
>>Male #18: Why didn't y'all leave us the
blueprint?
>>Male #19: We did leave you a blueprint.
>>Male #20: We did leave you a blueprint.
>>Male #21: We just didn't tell you where
it was.
>>Male #22: That's something that we dropped
the ball on.
>>Male #23: What do you fear?
>>Male #24: That something will harm my children,
and
>>Male #25: I fear success.
>>Male #26: Am I the only one who has problem
eating chicken, watermelon and bananas in
front of white people?
>>Male #27: Hah, hah, hah.
>>Male #28: Alright, that's crazy.
[laughing]
>>Male #29: That word, he has to stop using
it.
>>Male #30: I think black people can say "Nigga"
any time they want.
>>Male #31: How dare you?
What right do you have to use this word?
>>Male #32: Lot of "nigger" questions for
the rapper.
>>Male #33: What is common to all of us, that
we can say makes us who we are?
>>Male #34: Hm.
>>Male #35: This is the easiest question in
the world to answer.
>>Male #36: The thing that we have in common
is that we are male, and we are black.
[silence]
>>Male #37: My question is, I try to live
good, but I'm surrounded by bad.
And I wanna know, what it is I could do to
do better and live peaceful.
Surrounded by all evil.
How can I do that?
[silence]
>>Chris: So what that brief sequence does
is give you a sense of what we've tried to
do.
And that is, to take the deceptively simple
process of asking a question and put that
right into the heart of one of the most pressing
and troubling social concerns of our time.
And that is, the fact that the black community
is radically divided from itself.
The fact that black men are having to contend
with being one of the most opaque, and troubled
demographics in our time.
What we've done is just experiment with the
idea that black men not only have really deep
questions about all the concerns that affect
their lives.
But they also have the answers.
And putting them together, gives us a chance
to really understand from the position of
privileged witnesses, that this conversation
is very complex.
And it unfolds in the installation that we
created.
But it has a history, as she said, that began
with my experience when I was growing up in
Brooklyn.
This is a slide by the photographer Roy DeCarava.
And I use this as a way of illustrating the
way that I experienced Bed-Stuy when I was
growing up.
As a kid in the '40s and '50s.
At that time, the black community was still
forced to live in one community by itself.
I mean, there were many many generations and
many different socioeconomic classes.
I don't wanna oversimplify the fact that there
was obviously crime and lots of other issues.
But what I love about this slide is that it
gives a sense of the way I experienced the
black community as a child.
You see a mother, maybe walking her children
from school.
And that sense of being part of a community
that was a whole with all of the issues that
were part of it.
But then with the passage of the Civil Rights
laws, one of the unintended consequences was,
there was a split in the community.
Those who were able to leave the African American
community did.
So this next slide by Bruce Davidson is probably
more typical of the way people think of the
black community.
And it typifies a lot of the problems that
we suffer.
And so, what happened was, I left New York
when I was 17.
Came to California.
I was very lucky to have mentors.
That brought me into the photography world.
I studied photography with Ansel Adams, Judy
Dader, Winn Bullock.
And people like that.
And I became a professor at California College
of the Arts over the years.
And Suzanne Lacy who's renowned performance
artist.
She's really well known for going to communities
and trying to assess what the issues and values
in that community are.
And she and I formed a collaboration that
gave us a chance to work with kids like this
in high schools.
We created a project called "The Roof is On
Fire."
And what we did was, take the idea that young
kids if you create a safe environment around
them, will reveal truths that they'll withhold
from you if they are aware that you are there.
So what we did was, we put the kids in cars
on a rooftop.
We got the commission, the rooftop of a parking
garage.
We put 200 cars with kids in the cars and
we told the kids that they were to use the
car as a safe place to talk.
And so they had a badge around their necks
that said "Shut up and listen" and that was
a way for the audience to create an opportunity
to really hear the truth from their point
of view.
And they talked, as you can imagine, about
issues that were passionately important to
them.
They talked about sex, and drugs and values
and language.
And it was a really animated conversation.
But one of the things that inspired it was,
inspired the whole process, was that they
felt as if they were given permission to really
be listened to.
And you can see in this slide the woman in
the background, is performing the generous
act of listening to these young people.
And it was a really powerful experience.
And I think the people who saw it came away
with real different insights into what was
going on in the lives of these young people.
So that project was broadcast on KORN.
And I sort of became known in the art world
for doing projects like this.
And a few years later, I was commissioned
by the Museum of Photographic Arts in San
Diego to do a project called "Republic" And
they asked me to do something that related
to the black community.
And I thought back to that initial experience
I had as a young person of seeing the black
community divide into those who made a decision
to leave the community, to seek opportunities
and freedom.
Which is great.
But of course there is a cost to that.
And the one thing that I took away from the
initial experience was the fact that listening
is a passive form of being very generous.
But there's probably a more active way to
do that.
And that's asking a question.
So what I decided to do was give people on
both sides of this divide.
Those who live within inner city working class
neighborhoods and those who don't.
To ask questions of those on the other side
and vice versa.
So what you're seeing here is Keyona Johnson.
She's a woman who lives in the inner city
of San Diego.
And William Gaines.
And so I gave her a chance to ask questions
of him.
And vice versa.
So what I'm gonna show you is a brief clip
of this exchange.
[on video]
>>William: Have you given any thought to where
the money comes from for people who are receiving
public assistance?
And do you care?
>>Keyona: I've thought about where public
assistant money come from.
And I do care.
But for one, I am on public assistance and
it's not because we don't wanna work.
It's not because we wanna sit at home and
get a check.
Or anything like that.
A lot of people perceive us young teenage
mothers to sit at home and just collect a
check.
Where a lot of times, we do go out and look
for work.
We do work.
We can't work as long because childcare is
really up there.
At this point in time, I pay 300 dollars a
month and I have two.
And I pay 150 dollars a month for another
child.
The 300 is 'cause my child is under two.
The 150 is 'cause my child is over two and
is school age.
So yes, I know where the money comes from.
It comes from tax payers.
But we do have people who take up American
jobs who are not taxpayers.
Because they're not an American citizen.
How about that?
We get decreases in our checks because we're
American citizen.
But yet if you're a refugee or you're an immigrant,
or a legal working alien in the united states.
You get a increase in your check when you
come over here from different countries.
Because the united states government have,
so called, some kinda agreement with them.
They come over here and they're able to get
grants to start business.
Where we are already living here working,
doing the backbone of the country.
And we don't get that same type of respect.
But yeah, people look down upon us because
we are on public assistance.
They like to say "Oh, the black teenage moms,
they're going out openin' their legs and havin'
babies just to get on welfare, to get out
the house."
That is not always the case.
It's a small proportion that does that.
But you only focus on this small portion.
>>Chris: So you can imagine what it was like
for me to be in the middle of this process
and have this kind of really amazing truth
telling.
Just emerge spontaneously from the people
who were involved with it.
The piece that I put together for the MOPA
installation was an hour's worth of really
poignant questions and answers that came from
the people who were involved.
So I knew that somehow or another that this
process was animating something that these
people wanted to share.
Where did these incredibly articulate answers
come from?
So that's who Question Bridge was born.
I had ambitions back in '96 of it maybe becoming
an HBO documentary and going on.
It turned out not to happen that way.
Basically I sent it around to a bunch of friends.
Luckily one of the friends I sent it to was
the mother of Hank Willis Thomas.
And I think Hank will pick up the story from
here.
>>Hank: yeah.
So, I had [clears throat] I went to the California
college of the arts for graduate school when
I was photo major.
And I was one of Chris's students.
He was my mentor.
And along the way, I, both seeing image, seeing
a documentary of "The Roof is On Fire" but
I also saw him do a presentation on Question
Bridge.
And about three years after I graduated I
was offered an opportunity to apply for a
fellowship from the Tribeca Film Institute
for New Media.
And around the same time I came across a VHS
that my mother had of the Question Bridge
original installation.
And I, it struck me as having so much potential.
Because of the rawness with which the exchange,
happened.
And in fact one of the things Chris talked
about was the fact that you, if you have the
same people in the same room, having a discourse,
it'd be a lot more contentious.
And people would be less willing to listen
to each other.
But somehow by mediating a conversation through
video, it allows for a deeper way of listening
and a more sincere and earnest response.
And myself and one of our collaborators Bayete
Ross Smith who also went to CCA, were doing
a lot of work contending with issues about
the limitations of notions of black male identity.
Especially.
And I was really interested in how we could
use this Question Bridge model to speak to
what I saw as the diversity within the African
American male demographic.
Which kind of is frequently spoken about in
monolithic ways.
And so I approached Chris about how we could
possibly apply to do a Question Bridge about
black males.
And so over and through that we wound up traveling
with Bayete Ross Smith and then soon our fourth
collaborator Kamal Sinclaire came on board.
And then actors Jesse Williams and Delroy
Lindow.
And then my mother came on board as executive
producers to kind of help create this team
to kind of fulfill this kind of undetermined
mission.
At the time.
Which soon became this vision to represent
and redefine black male identity.
But the simplicity of the way the project
worked has already been expressed but this
is a brief illustration.
[video playing]
>>Male #33: My question to the black man in
America, or anywhere else, is, what is common
to all of us?
That we can say makes us who we are?
>>Hank: So we found this personality in Philadelphia
Pennsylvania.
And he asked this question.
And we then went around and found people to
answer the question.
And this is just one of the answers.
[video playing]
>>Male # 37: Our commonality is in our history.
But I think our beauty as black people is
also in our diversity.
>>Hank: And so at first we thought about just
doing this as a simple one to one.
Just one person asks the question, another
person answered it.
One of the real essential elements of the
project was this idea that we pride ourselves
in being a diverse nation, where everyone
has these kind of, can be, a space to be themselves.
But we all contend with narrow notions of
who we are at the end of the day.
And kind of live under these clouds of assumptions
about our own perception by other people.
But one of the things that we're really trying
to contend with at our project is, how do
people within that group relate to one another
and each other.
And how does that affect things like the achievement
gap, the discipline gap, the over representation
of black males in prison.
And one of the things that we really feel
like this project has the potential to do
is affect the major thing called "implicit
bias".
Which was a major factor in the Trayvon Martin
case where somebody sees a young black male
in a hood and makes this whole host of assumptions
about that person.
And that affects the way that many African
Americans, travel, navigate the world.
And African American men, especially, benefit
from people seeing more whole and diverse
representations of who they are.
Rather than seeing one or two or three people
actually seeing how each of them is a representation
of only themselves as individuals.
>>Chris: So this is an illustration of the
methodology.
Just to make it clear, what we really do,
as naive as it seems, is we simply touch black
men wherever we are.
We, there are instances where we saw a black
man who looked interesting.
There was a guy in Chicago who had a guardian
angel's hat on.
The very first man in our project was someone
sitting next to me on the plane.
That I said "This project is something that
gives black men who have questions about other
black men a chance to ask those questions
and get answers."
And so we would simply go around and we'd
say "Do you have a question you'd wanna ask
another black man you feel very different
from?"
And surprisingly black men no matter where
we were said "Sure, I have a question."
And so they would sit in front of our little
makeshift studio, and you can see me here
setting up lights around this person.
And we simply give them a chance to ask the
question.
So the questions come spontaneously from these
people.
And then you can imagine that once you've
built a critical mass of these really powerful
questions.
And one of the things that Hank said is that
this is perceived as an opportunity by the
men in it to really reach inside their own
lives and be reflective about what do they
think defines a difference between them and
somebody else.
You can imagine how different the project
would be, what a different dynamic it would
be if we said "Do you have a question for
someone that you admire?"
What you would get is a very very different
process.
And this man was a librarian in the museum
where we were appearing.
And.
>>Hank: Birmingham Alabama.
>>Chris: And because we had no idea what the
men were gonna ask, it was really remarkable.
So this is a good example.
[video]
>>Male #38: You know, I wonder, black man,
are you really ready for freedom?
And if not, what would it take for you to
want and need this freedom?
>>Chris: So you can imagine that once we have
these questions, you are kind of assigned
by the nature of the project to try to find
a place to get a poignant answer.
Because this question related to freedom,
one of the things that a lot of the issues
that came up dealt with was the issue of the
behavior of black men.
And so we knew that we needed to go to prisons
if that was possible.
I got the opportunity to teach meditation
at the county jail in San Francisco.
The administration there became comfortable
enough with me to allow us to bring in cameras
and lights.
And so we asked, we presented that question
in video form to this man.
And here's his answer.
>>Male #39.
Am I ready for freedom?
And what would it take for me to want that
freedom?
First I would have to stop and ax myself,
man.
That's a tough question.
'cause freedom to me is a mind state.
You know, because you got some people that's
not in jail that's not free.
You know, you got people that's in prison,
in dysfunctional relationships.
You got people that's in prison with jobs.
They work nine to five, that they don't like.
Some people are in prisons with alcohol and
drug abuse.
So I would have to, um, ax myself, what's
imprisoning me.
And what's been imprisoning me is self-esteem.
My lack of self-esteem.
My lack of self-esteem has led me to commit
crime.
To hurt people.
To manipulate people.
Because if I loved myself there's no way I
could walk outside this room and punish somebody.
And esteem within myself.
So to be free, to me, would have to be, I
would have to change.
You know.
So in order for me to grow I have to change,
because if change is necessary for growth,
in order for me to grow, I would have to adapt
the mentality of something's gonna have to
change in me.
I'd have to change my mind state.
I'd have to change the way I talk.
I'd have to change the people I interact with.
That would be "free."
>>Hank: So one of the things that was so fascinating
to me, actually having in the room with Chris
and Bayete when we showed this question.
That was his immediate, three seconds later
response to seeing that image on the screen.
And I think watching some of your faces here,
it's, your experience and that feeling that
we feel like really works for Question Bridge.
Like, how else were we gonna get someone to
give that kind of authentic response.
Or, if you walked up on the street corner
like, you know, do, what is it, you know?
Asked 'em that freedom question.
"Do you really feel free?"
Is that what are they gonna say?
Or you go to jail, whatever.
And I think that potency for the project was
something that really got us through the doors
and things like the Bay Area Video Coalition's
and the Producers Institute and Sundance where
we met Eric Dovesburger who works here at
Google.
And Sundance New Frontier story lab with Bayete
and Kamal Sinclair.
Went, were at BAVC—this is Kamal, kind of
being, kind of very efficient with our ideas.
And started to think about how all the ways
our project could work.
And initially we thought about doing a documentary.
And as we started to brainstorming, the documentary
kind of fell to like fifth place among the
ways the project could grow.
So we thought about the art installation.
There's a website that we're working on.
And then Kamal, Chris and Bayete put together
a curriculum that is being used and piloted
in ninth through twelfth grade classes in
the Bay Area and also in New York.
And then these community events that we've
been doing.
And then hopefully eventually it'll happen,
we can do the documentary.
But we approached Rene DeGuzman from the Oakland
Museum and also the Brooklyn Museum about
this idea of having a simultaneous launch
of the installation and we showed this kind
of 3D animation of how the installation might
work.
[many voices talking on animation]
>>Male #1 in animation: So much.
So many of you, using the racial slur.
And you know what word I'm talkin' about.
It's very serious.
We have to stop usin' it.
Why don't you stop?
>>Male #2 in animation: I think it's bullshit
that black people can't say "nigger."
I love saying "nigger" and I think it's' fantastic.
First of all it's one of the most beautiful
words to use in the English language because
it can express so much.
Much like the word "f---" The other thing
is, you can't give white people magic power
over us with a word.
Like if we stop saying a word because white
people use it poorly.
That's an absurdity.
And it also gives them much more power than
they would have if we just used the word freely
and enjoyed ourself with it.
We have much bigger issues.
>>Male #3 in animation: I think it's a ignorant
statement and I refuse to use it myself.
And I've heard the argument that by saying
it in popular culture we're desensitizing
the effect of this word.
I think that's foolish.
And it just blows me away when I hear people
who are not even black now, like other minorities
who are around black people when they say
this.
Have no idea of the historical significance
in this word.
And I think they're showing their own ignorance
by continuing to say this word in public.
>>Male #4 in animation: For myself, among
friends and people I've known for a long time,
and that we understand each other or feel
we understand each other, we can use that,
use "the N word."
That's the way I look at it, and I hate to
hear people, when they say you shouldn't use
the word in any setting, as if no other group,
no one ever discusses that other groups, racial
groups do the same thing.
They use the word among Italians, Polish,
Irish, I've heard them say it among themselves.
They call each other "dago," "pollack," "guinea,"
"mick," and, but you understand that you can't
use that word in their group.
And how it would be taken.
So it's a little different.
It depends on what setting you're in and who's
using the word.
Chris: So what you're seeing here is a CGI
that we put together to help us think through
how do we deliver this content.
What we've gathered is so precious.
I mean one of the things you saw on this slide
was the dynamic of a powerful question letting
loose so many different answers.
And we realized what we need to do is honor
all of those answers and give people a chance
to feel as if they were surrounded by these
black men in almost a sacred space.
That's why they're organized on five pillars
in kind of an arc.
So you have a chance to sort of be embraced
by the people that are talking.
And what we wanted the people who were witnessing
this to feel like as if they were sort of
invisible.
They were privileged witnesses to this very
intense conversation that has many dimensions.
'Cause what you see from this little sequence
is, a question like something like the word
"nigger."
Generates so many different answers.
There's no general agreement among black men
about how to relate to that word.
So one of the things that we felt like we
needed to do in putting together the installation
was honor that diversity of values and give
people a chance to see that there's an internal
debate that goes on within the greater consciousness
of black men about all these issues.
And the range of issues that this project
automatically generated was really almost
it was inspiring.
As she said earlier, we spent four years traveling
to a dozen cities around the country.
Sampling black men talking.
And one of the things that always surprised
us was as Hank said, how prepared these men
were to answer those questions.
So it gave us a chance to thing conceptually,
why was that possible.
It's certainly a pressurized situation when
you invite a stranger into the studio.
You put a camera and a monitor in front of
them and give them a chance to talk.
Why does it work?
And one of the things we realized is that
internally, marginalized people, and maybe
all of us, are sort of rehearsing answers
that to questions that float over us like
a cloud.
And so what we're doing is tapping into this
question cloud that people are looking for
opportunities to share.
So that's what Question Bridge is more than
anything else.
It's a vehicle for the transference of inner
truths that are always there and when you
tap into a demographic that really is underrepresented.
One of the things that we thought about is
that it's very much like giving Ralph Ellison's
"Invisible Man" a place to speak.
That's what this is about.
'Cause if you look at black men all around
you, they have so much to tell us about survival,
about accountability, about consequences.
One of the things that we were, it was vital
for us to do was not populate this project
with too many well-known black men.
We wanted it to feel as if you could walk
out and encounter any black man in the world.
And that would, that person could be part
of Question Bridge.
So we had this idea [chuckles] and then the
question is, what do you do with it?
And once it sort of formulated itself into
the idea of the installation, we were very
lucky to get an opportunity to do a presentation
at the Brooklyn Museum and much to our surprise
they embraced it.
Almost immediately.
And not only were they willing to commit a
six month installation of the show, but it's
actually still there.
But then they encountered Rene de Guzman who's
sitting here with us and Rene and Charles
Edemere decided to make a bi-coastal representation
of it.
So here's this representation of black men
talking on both sides of the country.
We also the next slide will show that we opened
this year at New Frontier at Sundance which
was a real honor.
We also simultaneously opened at the Utah
Museum of Contemporary Art and the City of
Atlanta committed the Chastain gallery to
a single channel version.
We'll be showing you a version of that shortly.
The way the five channel dynamics looks when
you condense it down to one channel.
These are installations, shots of the way
it appears in Brooklyn.
Every space of course has to treat it a little
bit differently.
At Oakland for example it's divided between
two galleries, and what it amounts to is a
three hour, five channel, high definition
experience.
You can imagine for us going to Sundance what
it was like to sort of be there as directors
of this high definition three hour movie.
And the project, as Hank said, organically
needed to represent itself in many different
ways.
So one of the different things we did was
collaborate with InnoVent, a software development
and web design company.
And we created this mobile app.
Because what we realized was that it was really
important for us to get the experience of
the presence of a black man asking you a question
out into the world.
So what the kiosk experience in the museums
allows you to do is have preselected questions
presented to you.
You get to identify yourself.
In terms of your demographic.
Also in terms of a few keywords that you think
define your sense of who you are.
And then you get to use the web cam built
into the kiosk, into the iPad, to actually
answer that question and present that back
to the world.
>>Hank: And this is yet another Google employee,
Bernardo Fernandez, was one of the first people
to come and test out the mobile app, and was
actually impressed by it, which we felt like
was a major achievement.
And so what was really exciting about actually
having the opening is seeing on, literally
dozens of people kind of crowd around this
installation.
And the fact that it is a five channel, three
hour installation is something we never expected
people to engage in on that level.
We tried to make it something that people
could exit or enter at any point.
We also made the education curriculum available
online.
So people could download it and engage with
their family, friends, but also of course
students.
And then
>>Chris: We should say that Kamal Sinclair,
our collaborator was really key in developing
that curriculum.
>>Hank: and then these ideas, one of the things
that Chris really, was most moved by early
on was this idea of this intergenerational
exchange.
And I witnessed that very much watching him
and Bayete relate.
Especially, I don't know, me and Bayete are
the same age.
But there's this really amazing kind of way
which as black men, they have such different
perspectives about things.
And have the three of us having these kind
of different couldn't agree on what issues
were central to black male identity.
While we're doing this project about black
males.
And so Chris, had this idea of why don't we
actually see what it's like to put this format
to test in the public.
Where we have this intergeneration exchange
where we had these things called blueprint
round tables.
[video starts]
>>Male on video: I'm trying to figure out
the parameters of blackness.
[video stops]
>>Hank: Whoa.
Whoa.
Oops.
Sorry.
I don't even know how that got in there.
Oops.
It was going so smoothly.
[laughs]
[audience laughs]
Let me see if I can skip that particular clip.
So this is a question that inspired this blueprint
roundtables.
We had our last one on Saturday in Oakland
which was supposed to be just a two hour exchange
which went on to be this four hour conversation
with hundreds of people that stayed.
And the one at the Oakland Museum was very
moving.
I got teary eyed, and it was pretty amazing.
But this is the question that inspired that.
[video starts]
>>Male #1: I love older people.
I respect older people.
I live for older people.
'cause I come from somebody that's older.
So first and foremost, I wanna say, we did
do wrong.
We did things, we stuck on ourself.
We did a lot of wrong things.
You know.
And for the most part, it's I don't respect
how you look down on us.
You treat us a certain type of way.
It's alright.
We gonna do it for the next 30 years.
We gonna show you all.
We gonna do what we gotta do.
But my whole thing is, my first and foremost.
I should have just said this from the beginning,
but I'm gonna sum it up with this.
Why didn't y'all leave us the blueprint?
Peace.
>>Male #2: I suppose some of us, myself included,
feel like we did leave a blueprint.
If you had experienced the euphoria that we
felt during the 60's,when we would see one
another on a corner, and there wasn't no such
thing as you had to throw up some kinda gang
sign.
When you saw the black people, you weren't
like this, they weren't like that.
Everything was just fine.
That's not the way it is now.
I thought, me as an individual 'cause I can't
speak to other people.
I thought there would be a continuum, I thought
if I raised my children a certain way that
things would stay that way.
I thought that we were progressing.
I underestimated the seriousness of our enemies.
I underestimated them.
That so much time and effort would be spent
in dismantling those things that brought about
self-esteem, those things that brought about
self-love.
Those things that brought about respect for
one another.
A great deal of time and energy was spent
dismantling that.
By our enemies.
And it is our fault.
That we did not see that for what it was.
And combat it more thoroughly.
>>Male #3: I think maybe we did leave you
a blueprint.
And yet, we too were so busy trying to survive,
that we were not as organized and disciplined
as maybe we should have been.
But speaking from the platform of Martin Luther
King's civil right's movement.
Martin Luther King never had more than 100
people on his staff.
And that was only for one or two movements.
He never had more than a half a million dollars
a year to try to change the world.
None of us had a blueprint.
But what he taught us to do and what we learned
from Gandhi in India, was that we could find
our own way by standing up for the truth.
>>Male #4 Well, after the civil rights movement
of the 60's proved to be very very successful,
I think blacks felt that we have crossed a
threshold, and it's easy going from here on
in.
But the worst was yet to come.
I kinda think we thought that the waves would
continue to roll.
And we did drop the ball.
Only to find out later that other people were
making plans and were putting certain kinds
of Negroes in heads of organizations and paying
them well.
And they became the spokespersons for black
people.
And they became the protectors of the plantation.
Being paid by white people.
>>Male #5: I think that we left you the blueprint,
we just didn't tell you where it was.
It's there.
But we didn't just show it to you or lay it
out.
You had to look at us and see what we were
doing to find out.
How to go about that blueprint.
You see, some things can't be explained to
you.
Some things you gotta look at a person and
then you gotta see what it is that they're
doing.
The blueprint is, you get an education.
You don't just be in the middle of the road.
You don't try to be with the kids who don't
do well.
You try to be the best.
OK?
You do as good as you can, no matter how angry
people become when you're really good.
You know, what?
Success is not easy.
It is not.
If it was, everybody would be successful.
It takes time.
It takes hard work.
And everybody's not geared for hard work.
Some people want it overnight.
And it's not gonna happen that way.
So what you have to do it, we old people,
we've laid the groundwork for you.
We've already put the blueprint out there.
Now you might not like that blueprint.
You might wanna alter it in some way.
And you can.
But if you alter it, and it's not for the
better, you will not achieve what us old folks
have achieved.
>> Chris: So again, you can imagine.
You can see that what we're doing is, we're
telling a story.
We're allowing the men in this project to
tell the story.
And in this case there was a hunger for an
intergenerational exchange that doesn't happen
when the men don't have fathers and grandfathers
who are there.
And so this project becomes a vehicle for
talking between generations.
[video starts]
>>Male #6: I'm tryin' to figure out the parameters
of blackness.
I know there's stuff that I'm supposed to
believe and read and listen to and look at
if I'm definitely gonna be black.
Like in a heart of blackness.
But I keep wondering, Suppose for example
I prefer to listen to classical music?
Or I prefer to travel to places where there
are no black people?
Or I like Picasso maybe even more than I like
Romare Bearden or Jacob Lawrence.
Am I still black?
Or exactly how do we figure out where these
boundaries are.
Or what we're supposed to be if we want to
be a part of this community?
>>Male #6: Oh my God.
I am so f---ing sick of regulatory blackness.
Because this is what your question is all
about.
What do I have to do in order to prove my
blackness.
Let me just answer your question like this.
I know I come from a rich tradition that is
diverse as it is deep.
I don't have to do particular things in order
to prove that I'm more or less black.
I mean, that's absolutely ridiculous and I
think it makes us schizophrenic.
I think it makes us crazy to run around thinking,
well, if I don't listen to hip-hop, I'm not
black enough.
Um, if I go to rock concerts or something
like that, I'm being white.
If I do this or if I do that, I'm not seen
as being a full black person in the black
community.
F--- that shit.
I'm black.
I'm proud of that.
And I don't have to adhere to all these cultural
norms in order to prove that.
>>Male #7: See, I've always believed in dealing
with different type of people.
I never was set in stuck in like one type
of box.
So, basically the answer for that is, like,
you can do basically whatever you wanna do.
Just always remember that everything comes
from black.
You know what I mean?
So if like, you can deal with whoever you
wanna deal with.
I like white people.
I gotta few white friends.
You know what I mean?
And there's not nothin' wrong with that.
It's your choice to do what you wanna do.
But just always remember, try to rub off and
always try to take what you need to take from
certain people and do what you need to do
with them, and create whatever you wanna create.
Brothers.
>>Hank: This is one of the more compelling
exchanges that we came across.
Which I think when we heard this question,
I was, that was the first one when I was like
OK, I think we've reached our, our stopping
point.
Whereas, Chris decided to forge forward and
you kind of see where it led us.
[video starts]
>>Male #1: Alright, cool, so this is my question.
I've got a lot of brotha's in the hood, listenin'
to a lot of rap music.
And I just wanna know, what is so cool about
selling crack?
Cause someone tell me that.
Why is that so glorified in the music and
the things that we talk about?
>>Male #2: Well, for myself, when I came up
crack was a quick way for a black man to make
a million dollas.
I'm 40 years old.
In '85 when the crack scene hit.
I was 15, 16 years old.
Watching two parents work dog hard to death.
And watchin' the dude next door who was selling
crack ride big cars.
To me, I thought that was cool.
And once I learned how to sell crack, and
learned how to acquire my own money.
And steal, learn how to have things white
folks was havin' and get up when I wanted
to get up.
To me, that was cool.
>>Male #3: To me, crack is wack.
But to most people I think, why to most people
my age and where I come from, my community,
I think it's cool because you could make money.
You know, you could really just sit on your
butt and, you know, make some money.
Don't really have to do nothin' except you
have to watch for cops and you be paranoid
and everything.
>>Male #4: Ain't nothing cool about being
up there.
Taking life chances.
Sitting on my corner.
Not knowin' what's gonna occur at any given
minute.
Tryin' to get some, what material possession.
[coughing]
Ain't nuttin' cool out there.
I mean, oppressing my people because I'm hurt.
Hurt people hurt people.
Ain't nuttin' cool with that.
Ain't nuttin cool with me sellin' crack to
my mama.
Takin' the Christmas toys away from my little
siblings.
'Cause I'm charging my mama a hunnred for
a dime on credit.
>>Male #3: I believe, like, sellin' drugs
is just, um, as much of an addiction as the
person that is using it.
You know, you see that money, you get a high.
>>Male #4: I gotta answer for everything I
do.
My actions and my inactions.
And I've been a part of bullshit.
And I didn't see it on the streets, I was
blinded to what, the delusion of grandeur.
Thinkin that I'm greater than life itself.
And I wasn't.
you feelin' me?
I'm responsible for hella hurt that I caused
people like broken families out there.
I'm responsible for children that's incarcerated
right now as we speak.
I'm incarcerated for death out there based
on me selling crack because I never know what
a person had to do to go get it.
You feelin' me?
I'm responsible for that shit.
Ain't nuttin cool with that.
And at nighttime I sit and I sleep in my cell
man.
And I sit there lost in thoughts man.
Damn.
I'm responsible for a lot of things.
And um [sighs] Man.
I ain't know why it's up for that.
Just sitting here with the bullshit that I
created.
Just sittin' here and watch my people sit
here and cry.
I'm responsible for everything.
I hold myself accountable.
Shit.
But I been committed suicide a long time ago
when I was a part of that bullshit.
Now I claim my life.
And I'm a part of something that's greater.
And that's the solution.
>>Chris: [sighs] So, again, you can imagine
what it was like to be in the presence of
that kind of disclosure that came spontaneously
from this man just given an opportunity to
do it.
The same thing is true in this example here.
We had no idea what this man was gonna ask.
[video starts]
>>Male #1: This may seem like a silly question.
I wanna know, am I the only one who has a
problem eat'n chicken, watermelon, and bananas
in front of white people.
[other men laugh and comment]
>>Male #2: I don't have a problem with it.
Period.
>>Male #3: No, I'm gonna be honest with you.
I don't even eat watermelon because of the
connotations that it has around black people.
Um, but I will eat some chicken though.
[men laugh]
>>Male #4: I never heard the bananas one.
I never heard.
Bananas, really?
>>Male #5: I don't know if you the only one,
but it's not a problem for me to eat whatever
I wanna eat in front 'a anybody.
>>Male #6: you're not the only one brother,
to be honest.
Every time I still eat chicken.
I eat a lot of watermelon.
And I love bananas.
But I'm always lookin' over my shoulder.
Wherever I'm at, seein' who's watching me
eat this watermelon and this piece of chicken.
And this banana.
Always.
You not the only one.
>>Male #7: No, I know plenty of African Americans
who as a rule will not eat watermelon in front
of white folks.
Now, for me, I've difficulty relating to the
question only in the sense that I've never
ever liked watermelon.
[laughter]
And I don't eat meat.
So I don't find myself in the situation [laughs]
where chicken and watermelon comes to a head.
But I do know that there are times where you
feel like you are the stereotype.
Because you know, if they say "Hey do you
wanna go play some basketball?"
And of course I love basketball.
I played it every single day.
But there's a part of me that wants to say
"Nah.
I don't wanna play any basketball.
What makes you think I wanna play basketball?"
But in those moments, I think we have to be
honest with ourselves.
And just know that there are some things that
are true.
Yes.
You know.
We like chicken.
We like watermelon.
And there's nothin' wrong with that and it's
nothin' to be ashamed of.
>>Male #8: it's not a silly question brother.
My family sells 50,000 pounds of watermelon
every week in the streets of South Chicago,
Milwaukee, and Gary, Indiana.
And have been since 1953.
And we're OK with that.
[laughter]
And by the way, I like fried chicken.
'Fact, I'm gonna make some tonight.
>>Male #9: I don't know if you're the only
one ashamed.
I'm not ashamed, but I do give chicken a second
thought sometimes.
Even when I mention it.
But I always pass it off as sort of like in
a jokey joke way.
'Cause I do love chicken.
Watermelon.
I don't eat watermelon so much.
So I'm not really so much ashamed of it.
Bananas, I hadn't thought about bananas because
I was always thinking about banana, because
I'm gay in a sexual way.
So when I put a banana, I'm always self conscious
in front of anybody.
Just because, sexuality.
But not because of race.
[laughter]
>>Male #10: I thin really the question leads
to a deeper question.
Why are we so concerned what they think about
us?
I mean, you know, that's what the real question
is.
I don't really care.
You know, I know somewhere in there, I do
care, but in my consciousness and what I'm
gonna say is, I don't really care what they
think.
You know, I don't need their approval in order
for me to go ahead and be me.
Or for me to do my job.
You know, or for me to be who I'm gonna be.
I don't need their approval.
I don't need their jaw.
None of that.
You know, I think it's' really important that
we stop worrying about what they think and
start worrying about what you think about
yourself.
And maybe what the little black kid next door
to you thinks about you.
F--- some white person thinkin' about what
they think about you eatin' a watermelon or
anything else.
Your shoes, your jacket.
Your hat backwards.
I don't go with the saggin' pants but you
know, whatever you do.
And that's because it's your cultural identity
or your food or whatever.
What they think about it is not really important.
>>Hank: So this is, and you saw that exchange
between the heaviness of the crack questions
and kind of the, I think the, we have so many
other, my favorite answer to that particular
question isn't even in here.
Because we had, there's so many different
kind of answers and what we found is everyone
is an expert about something.
Everyone like, we found this guy who said
my family's sold watermelons for 60 years.
You know, like these are the kind of things
that lie beneath, in every one of us in this
room there's all these things that we don't
ever think about how they relate, how we relate
to one another.
I'm gonna skip this one.
And then show you this clip and then we're
gonna pretty soon wrap up.
[video starts]
>>Boy: I have a question.
How do you know when you become a man?
>>Male #1: Wow, that's deep question for such
a young person.
How would you know when you become a man.
Well, basically, responsibility.
You're able to take on assume responsibility.
Hold fast to your commitments to yourself
first, your family and the community of which
you live in.
And if you can do those things, you're on
your way to manhood.
>>Male #2: The question of when you become
a man, you're born a man.
When you become of age, may be a more relevant
question.
But some of us become of age, many many times
throughout the course of their lives.
I thought that I was a man at 21, ready to
write memoirs of all my experience.
You know.
And so I don't know how many times that I
thought I knew the answer to everything.
And so I'm here again [laughs] thinking that
I know it all.
But you, you'll know.
>>Male #3: Young man, there are a couple of
different factors that make you a man.
You have to be financially stable.
That's one.
You definitely got to have your own place.
Own roof over your head.
You have to go to college.
You know that's for all the young men out
there.
That's one step that you gotta take in order
to lead to financial stability.
And you have to be taking care of yourself.
And buy your mama a house.
Then you become a man.
[laughter]
>>Male #4: I think sometimes, I still try
to answer that question, whether or not I've
become a man.
I grew up in a single family home without
a father.
But I'm the youngest of seven and I have six
older brothers who taught me about being a
man.
And so part of that is trying to be responsible
to my family.
And to my loved ones.
And being a responsible citizen.
But I think each of us have to find our own
way to that path.
Of what it means to be a man.
>>Male #5: Young brother, it, you know, I
knew I became a man when I had to take on
certain responsibilities and obligations with
family, community and otherwise.
>>Male #6: Oh, that's a fine question there.
I think that one of the mistakes that we often
make is thinking that the first time that
we're intimate with a woman, that now we're
a man.
In traditional societies, in order for boys
to go into manhood, they had to go through
certain rituals which included them being
prepared to fit whatever role they had in
that society.
If they were hunters, they'd learn how to
hunt.
If they were farmers, they'd learn how to
farm.
If they were fishermen, they learned how to
fish.
And when they were through with everything
that prepared them to be a responsible member
of that particular community and that particular
town or village or tribe or whatever, they
were given visible symbols of their completion.
A scar on the face, a type of clothing, a
type of jewelry or something that they wore
that a woman could look at them and say "Well
this person is now a man."
>>Male #7: Young'un, Young'un.
Hooo.
I'm still tryin' to figure that out myself.
Um, it's, it's tough.
It's really tough.
I just for me, I really don't know when that's
gonna happen.
Right now I'm just trying to take these strides
in what society thinks a man is, you know.
Going to school and getting a job, and being
able to stand on my two feet.
It's gonna be a difficult road.
But It's probably gonna be well worth it.
>>Hank: So, we have all of this content.
We have actually more than 1500, we have almost
2000 now, question answer exchanges.
And so we worked with Ryan Alexiev, who's
here also today to kind of start to, he also
designed our iPad app.
And we have a beta form of a mobile app that
we did with InnoVent.
But the main thing that we're really hoping
to get to as engagement energies are these
posters that we can distribute and a lot of
people using QR codes and
>>Chris: NFC tags.
>>Hank: NFC tags to actually respond to questions
from their mobile devices.
But also to log onto our website which we
hope someday soon will be user generated.
Where you can kind of look at questions, upload
your own answers to questions and then have
these different ways of searching questions
and answers through this integrated identity
map.
As well as a map based on what kind of values
people are kind of representing.
Through locations, and things like that.
And then lastly just using the slide of one
of Bayete Ross Smith, one of our collaborator's
work.
To show kind of how our hopefully we, our
ultimate goal of the Question Bridge will
lead to showing that within each individual
is a much more complex and diverse human being
that no one could be deduced to a simple demographic
stereotype or notion.
>>Chris: one of the ways that we symbolize
that is by emphasizing that the title of this
project is Question Bridge, colon, Black Males.
The colon is really important.
There really is no reason why this methodology
couldn't be applied to any demographic.
And that's one of our aspirations.
>>Hank: Especially when it's not even race
or gender specific.
Question Bridge Google.
>>Chris: So thank you.
[laughter]
>>Hank: Thank you all.
[applause]
>>Stacy: Feel free to ask questions with the
mic.
>>Audience Member #1: So I, your project is
a fascinating amalgam of psychology and sociology
and politics and art and I guess my question
is about the artistic and the maybe political
part.
Or anthropological part.
I don't know.
But as the people doing the selection curation
of this material, and deciding how to present
it and which parts of it to present to the
people who interact with it or, and become
a part of the project, in that way or to the
people who maybe go to the Oakland Museum
and view the installation.
Obviously you bring some biases very openly
to your selection process and you've articulated
some of them.
Like there's value in the diversity of this
demographic.
And I'm sure you probably have a very conscious
awareness of the role that your biases play
in the selection of this stuff.
And which parts are you gonna emphasize, which
are the interesting parts.
I'm interested in your comments about how
do you decide which are the right biases to
apply in choosing the material?
And which ones are the ones that you might
try to suppress?
>> Chris Johnson: Well, I think the essence
of that goes back to the fact that as I said
at the beginning of this, this is a project
that even though it does share methodologies
and values that anthropology, sociology, psychology
does, journalism, for example.
All of those are pursuits of truth, but because
it's a work of art, what drives all those
decisions are, first of all, the initial experience
that we feel like we wanna convey.
I mean, that's primary.
And because the initial experience of this
is our experience as black men, our understanding
of how complex we are as individuals.
Our experience of the fact that because we
are marginalized, I use the notion of us being
opaque.
That the mission of this as artists is to
have visibility.
For those black men.
And so what we wanna do is listen very carefully
to the stories that emerge.
And then sense where there's an implied narrative
arc, like where the meaning lies by the juxtaposition
and sequencing of these questions.
And you can see that in the sequences.
So you make those decisions intuitively.
Hoping you're creating an experience that
becomes an exchange between us as artists
and you as viewers.
And then you use formal strategies, of course
the framing.
And I talked a little bit about the way the
installation is designed.
You know try to be inclusive.
Those are all things that are driven by our
sensibilities as artists.
And then we hope that experience is transformative
for the viewers.
>>Hank: Well, I agree with him to a degree.
I think one of the things he didn't mention
'cause he's being diplomatic is, we argue.
[chuckles] Because it's a collaboration and
it's a collaboration and the making of a five
channel, three hour project, you have, we
have like six or seven voices involved.
And not all of them are African American males.
And we each have different subjects.
Different people who, like this is, I love
this person or I love that person.
And I think part of the reason that its' also,
it becomes more complex is because no one
single vision is defining this conversation.
We're very sensitive to that aspect.
The only reason its' even three hours is because
we didn't have time to make it six hours.
Because we have over 85 hours of like really
great content.
And I think, you know, if Chris were left
to his own devices.
If I was left, I'd make it one thing, and
that's, I think this project, one of the things
that it really tries to challenge is this
idea of an authoritative narrative voice.
That within especially social sciences says,
I have an expert from the outside that's gonna
come in and apply these generic kind of format
to finding out information about a certain
group.
Whereas our project is really organic.
you know, Chris will walk up to somebody on
the street.
Or Bayete will call somebody in another place.
Or Kamal will say, oh I happen to know.
Everybody happens to know some black man somewhere.
So the diversity is implied in the way that
we find people.
And then we show them questions and when we
first, Chris asked them to pose a question
and they would give a question and the bias
was in me, Chris, and Bayete's selection of
question we showed them based off the question
they asked.
>>Chris: But let me just give a further answer.
What emerged as Hank said, was in a sense,
a synthesis of two key things.
One of them had to do with healing.
And so you heard me talk about how the project
was for me a chance to try to create a connection
between these different segments of the African
American community.
Who for historical reasons were separated
and needed each other.
So that one has a sense of empowerment and
freedom to move through opportunities and
the greater world.
Others have a strong sense of community, belonging
to each other.
And so, wanting to heal that.
So healing became one theme.
And that could have been the driving force
behind the whole project.
But another one emerged that was really important.
And that is representation.
The opportunity of black men through this
format to speak and define themselves.
Without an author telling them what to say,
and how to say it.
And so those dynamics played out even within
a particular sequence.
And that's what gives it such depth and richness,
I think.
>>Male audience member #1: Thank you.
>>Male audience member #2: I just have a quick
question.
Do you guys ever film reactions?
When they hear like 15 different answers,
like how their opinions might have changed
after that.
>>Hank: you wanna take that?
>>Chris: Well, sure.
As you can imagine part of the process entails
filming the person while they're listening
to the question.
Sometimes that's really important.
And the way that would work, this is something
Hank and I did sort of telepathically.
He would give me a cue that this question
is gonna prompt a response.
And I would be really careful to capture that.
And then you could see how we used some of
that footage.
The headers.
In and out of a question.
As a way to create a dynamic of exchange in
the installation.
And so we definitely captured as much of that
as possible.
But one technical thing, working in digital
video, you become very mindful of disc space.
So we sometimes would see things running out
and so we more, conservative about what we
captured.
But yeah, that was part of it.
That was part of it.
>>Hank: But also one of the factors of Chris's
original question for this project.
I wish we had the time to do, was to take
certain, and Chris especially has ambition,
a mission, to go back and find the man who
asked the peaceful question.
And show him the range of answers we got to
that question.
And I think the, basically a rebuttal.
That that was part, you did.
>>Chris: Closing the loop.
>>Hank: Closing the loop.
And the original Question Bridge project that
we haven't really had a chance because we
have to track down these 160 men.
But we will.
>>Female audience member: On that note, thank
you very much for coming to Google today.
[applause]
[jazz music plays]